hey this is presh talwalkar
find all solutions in non-negative
integers a and b
such that the square root of a plus the
square root of b is equal to the square
root of two thousand twenty-three
that's part 1 of the question
part 2 is a coding challenge and i will
present a solution in python let's say
you are given a non-negative integer n
write a program to find all solutions in
non-negative integers a and b
such that the square root of a plus the
square root of b is equal to the square
root of n
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
we begin by tackling the first part of
the question
whenever you have square roots it's a
good idea to try to eliminate the square
roots
we will first solve for the square root
of a
then we will square both sides to get
that a is equal to the square of the
square root of 2023 minus the square
root of b
we then expand the binomial to get a is
equal to 2023 plus b minus 2 times the
square root of 2023 b
now let's analyze this equation
a is a non-negative integer
2023 is an integer
b is an integer
the only part of the equation that might
not be an integer is the square root of
2023 multiplied by b
so we'll notice that if and only if this
square root evaluates to be an integer
we will have a solution
so
we have a condition
that will find a solution if and only if
the square root of 2023 multiplied by b
is a natural number including 0.
then the prime factorization of 2023 is
7 multiplied by 17 squared so this is
equivalent to 17 multiplied by the
square root of 7b
now this will evaluate to be a natural
number if the square root of 7b is a
natural number
so b is equal to 7 multiplied by x
squared where x is a non-negative
integer
so that's the condition for a solution
here
by very similar logic we can solve for
the square root of b
and figure out a condition in this case
so that a is equal to 7 multiplied by y
squared where y is a non-negative
integer
so we figured out some conditions for b
and a
we'll substitute that into our original
equation
from here we can simplify because x and
y are non-negative integers
so we have y multiplied by the square
root of 7 plus x multiplied by the
square root of 7 is equal to 17
multiplied by the square root of 7.
we divide both sides by the square root
of 7 so we have the simple equation x
plus y is equal to 17 for non-negative
integers x and y
this is very easy to solve
we have 0 17 1 16
to 15 and so on we have a total of 18
pairs
we can then substitute in for x and y
to get the pairs a and b
so we'll end up with 18 pairs of
solutions as shown on the screen
and that's the answer to the first part
of the question
so now we need to take this analysis and
generalize it
let's say we are given a non-negative
integer n and we want to find all
solutions in non-negative integers a and
b such that the square root of a plus
the square root of b is equal to the
square root of n
how do we do that
well let's go over a critical part of
the proof
in this analysis we saw the critical
condition was that we had a solution if
and only if the square root of 2023
multiplied by a was a natural number
so
in our general case we're going to have
a solution if and only if the square
root of n multiplied by a is a whole
number
so let's put this idea into pseudo code
we're going to write a function solution
n
we need to have a go over the values of
0 to n
we'll evaluate if the square root of a
multiplied by n is an integer then we
can compute the value of b
and we will return an array of all
ordered pairs a and b that are solutions
so let's implement this in python this
is not going to be the most efficient or
best code it's just going to be useful
for explaining the solution
so we'll import the math library we're
going to define a solution n
we initialize a list for the result
for a in the range 0 to n plus 1
a will go over the values of 0 to n
we compute the value of b
then if b is an integer
we're going to add the pair a
and the integer b
to the solution
list
and we continue this loop
eventually we return the result of all
these ordered pairs
so let's try n is equal to 16.
we're going to print all the solutions
here
to get a better sense of the code we can
use python tutors code visualization
which visualizes the code line by line
we import the math library we define the
solution we have the value n is equal to
16 and we will print all the solutions
so we go to the function solution 16 we
first initialize an empty list we start
with a is equal to zero we evaluate b we
check if it's an integer if it is we add
the pair a comma b we do this for a is
equal to 1 we get another solution and
we continue this loop for a is equal to
2 and so on and it will continue until a
is equal to 16.
in the meanwhile we keep adding ordered
pairs a b
if we find out that a and b are integer
solutions
this stops at a is equal to 16 and thus
we are going to return the list result
and we get the following pairs of 0 16 1
9 4 4 9 1 and 16 0 and those are all the
solutions for n is equal to 16.
what's amazing about putting this into
computer code is that we can input other
values of n
we can then visualize all of these
solutions just at the click of a button
this is what happens as n goes over all
these other integer values and we just
get the results of all these ordered
pairs
it's so amazing to commute these things
so quickly we don't have to go through
each case by case
now there is a hitch as we incorporate
computer code into our solution
there are all sorts of difficulties when
you start coding so in this vein i had a
computer programmer evaluate my code and
he gave me some feedback i want to thank
rohit for his help he suggested the
following python code we import the math
library then we define calc b
as a function of a and n
this will return the value of b based on
a and n then we can define the solution
n in one line
so there are all sorts of ways that you
can do this so i think it's wonderful if
we can incorporate coding into
mathematics
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve the world's problems one video at
a time